and who the title is not clickbait this
guru who sells in a thousand dollar
youtube course for like how to be
successful on YouTube
faked being on Ellen
like he just photoshopped himself onto
you know the thing here's whom in TVs
clip that he does in his little sales
pitch of like look how awesome I am I
was on Ellen and then here's the actual
Ellen clip let's see if we can do some
spectral analysis here really
oh I'm these up this is just like clown
world at this point the the places gurus
will go to get credibility is amazing to
me because if they don't have
credibility they'll just make it up
right it doesn't matter like if I don't
have credibility oh yeah sure I was on
that one I was if you believe it I mean
like yeah sure this guy says Justin
Bieber shout at him and I've been shared
by people like Justin Bieber Shaquille
O'Neal Drake and many more yeah just a
beeper he's all about gold digger pranks
which is what this guy does like on his
main channel
yeah those gold digger pranks are
hilarious Shaq shouts about you know
shampoo pranks for the best you know
Shaq he's all about the shampoo pranks
they did my personal favor Drake says
he's a comedy legend comedy legend it's
just you know you know how it is like
Seinfeld
you know there's Norm Macdonald and then
there's like you know whom in TV you
know with such all-star comedies like
gold digger pranks 1 part 2 part 3 part
4 part 5 part 6 part 7 part 8 and part 9
part 10 and you're a gold digger because
you're frickin gold digger see what a
gold digger in Miami looks like you are
a gold digger dick cuz I mean you know
you're a gold digger and there's gold in
there for you so just dig for some gold
[Music]
you know you're a gold-digger oh my gosh
how do these guys sell them $2,000 of
course with a straight face I have no
idea its mind-blowing to me the
advertising on this stuff like how do
you put out lies that are so provably
false like when you say you you know
when you say you know I was featured on
all these channels I mean you show a
clip of Ellen laughing at your thing you
know we can just look that up right I
think what I think what it is is that
you know these business coaches have
been preaching fake it until you make it
for so long like fake it you make it
fake it to make it fake it till you make
it and I think you know sure in some
small doses that's fine confidence even
fake confidence if we gets more
confidence but if you don't don't fake
like the success you don't have and the
funny thing is is this guy is not a bet
like he's not a nobody youtuber he's a
huge YouTube like why don't you just go
off say like I have millions of
subscribers why do you have to lie what
do you have to I don't have
who does this who pretends to be on
Ellen what's going on guys who man here
back with another gold digger prank
today we're doing something different
I'm standing here with my boy Kevin
David
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]